bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
aux championnats du monde 2016 féminin
entre donc la chinoise hou yifan et
l'ukrainienne music you mariah donc
cinquième partie du match où les fans
mène 2 1 points suite à sa victoire dans
la première partie
elles viennent d'annuler avec les blancs
dans la 4e et à la 5e et se retrouve de
nouveau avec les pièces blanches
il n'ya pas d'alternance à cette ronde
là parce que en fait on est en milieu de
match et à ce moment là ils ont décidé
dans le règlement de ré inverser les
couleurs l'ordre des couleurs à partir
de cette cinquième partie voilà donc ici
ou iphone a de nouveau les blancs et
donc marié musi tout cas la difficile
tâche donc d'essayer de tenir deux fois
de suite avec les noirs mais après si
elle tient cette partie pourquoi pas
donc essayer de revenir au score avec
deux fois les blancs de belles
opportunités s'ouvrent à elle pour
essayer de rééquilibrer ce match un
match qui décidément est bien tient ses
promesses pour l'instant on a eu peur au
début je l'avouer
d'une défaite rapide mais non et le ti
elles tiennent bien la championne du
monde elle se laisse pas déborder et
elle garde ses chances alors il faut
avoir falloir voir dans cette partie ce
que ça donne alors c'est parti on y va
tout de suite avec up c4 alors voilà
donc là c'est ça c'est une surprise
parce que pour l'instant la jouer que le
4 la chinoise yi fan et elle joue c4
donc elle variait l'oci comme mariam
titre ou alors peut-être et s'est aperçu
que bombay rien à avait bien tenu
finalement dans son espagnol et elles
changent elles changent d'approché
on y va c'est 6 pour l'instant c'est un
coup bon qu'on peut qualifier de partie
anglaise au début avec ce coup c4 et la
réponse c'est 6 on invite les blancs à
jouer des quatre des cinq dans une slave
ou une demi slave
on va voir ce que ça donne cavalier f3
le coup le plus souple on ne donne pas
encore d'indication est-ce qu'on va se
pousser ce pion de deux cases d'une
seule case c'est pas les mêmes variantes
et raté 5
voilà donc direct un maillet musi choo
qui va direct le tergiverse pas et j'ai
3 g iii alors ça c'est un coût qui peut
faire rentrer d'encore beaucoup variante
ici parce que on pourrait bien sûr avoir
bien une
une sorte de toujours dents gleizes ou
2,4 alors dès qu'il ya des cas j'ai
trois enfants des catalanes aussi ça
dépend les coûts qui suivent
et puis ça dépend aussi bien sûr de la
réponse - donc ça reste très souple argy
six mois la g6
on va rentrer le système indienne
système indien donc fou j'ai deux fous
j'ai sept indiens ou grünfeld en fait
voilà on a les fous en sciant kétou donc
c'est des systèmes que les joueurs de
fientes y est tous connaissent bien ont
pas de panneau problème d'ouverture ici
un essor ceci d'ouverture assez facile à
jouer parce qu'il n'y a pas de gros
piège il faut juste faire attention à
pas perdre trop de temps à jouer
correctement les courses à cinq routes
menant à damas 4/5 coup si damas quatre
ça c'est un coup un peu inattendu c'est
assez rare de jouer ce genre de coups
comme ça où la dame tôt alors qu'on n'a
pas encore sorti ni cavaliers nil fou on
n'a pas ok damas quatre alors sa menace
pas grand chose si ce n'est peut-être
prendre des cinq et on peut pas
reprendre du pied puisqu'il est cloué
bon à noter aussi qu'en cas de prise en
c4 bien je peux reprendre de la dame
pourquoi pas bon apparemment la prévu
coup c'est ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
pions francéclat d'emprunt c4 très bien
pourquoi pas un peu surprenant la dame
aime peut avancer comme ça elle est là
se faire chasser tôt ou tard par un coup
comme saucisses va pas rester longtemps
ici mais bon eux cinq bien cinq alors
pourquoi en scène tout de suite mais je
pense que tout simplement d'abord on est
défendue par le faux bien sûr on peut
menacer plus tard de jouer aux cartes
pas pour l'instant mais la dame mais
peut-être pour jouer justement faut 6
dans ce cas là on met pas le fou devant
un pion qu'on n'a pas empêché le pion
d'avancé on libère un peu de l'espace
pour la noire et puis surtout on y va la
case de 7 pour la cavalière on veut
développer ce cavalier en hausse est
très probablement afin de ne pas boucher
l'action de ce fou voilà donc on vit
d'abord le pion et ensuite on mettra le
cavalier et en plus on a préparé faut
600 bloqués le pion en recettes
voilà voilà il faut être précis pas très
compliqué mais il faut être précis dans
le dans l'ordre lors des trois des trois
c'est logique on rajoute du contrôle sur
quatre et puis on libère bien sûr le fou
c'est un qui va pouvoir se développer
kb s est très bien petit rock et
cavaliers assis sa parole tout de suite
alors à pure ok aussi mais bon callas
lice alors ça c'est peut-être un tout
petit peu un petit peu piégeux ça je ne
sais pas alors qu'est ce qui se passe
pas sur un coup comme on peut regarder
sur cavalli c3 regardez ce cavalier
contrôler ces deux cases la dame est
presque prise regarder les pions ici là
le pion ici contrôle bon il reste encore
des cases là mais c'est pas des cases
très très sûrs en 4 ou 1 h 4 c'est une
dame qui peut toujours être attaqué bref
il ya un coup comme fou aussi c'est
voilà il n'y a pas beaucoup de classe
pour la dame mais y en a quand même
c'est à dire qu'ici si on joue et quand
même faut 6 nous il faut faire attention
déjà on sera obligé de revenir en a
quatre on a encore cette case il compare
à rentrer à la maison on n'a pas peur du
temps quand même
voilà alors que l'idée de la dame
peut-être cette venir en c2 plutôt que
derrière à quatre où elle fit rien en c2
en un petit oeil sur e4
on protège le pion détroit enfin par
transparence avec des troncs contrôle
mieux 4 et on mettra la dame derrière
deux cavaliers ce qui est toujours mieux
que de le mettre devant comme ça où elle
est a quand même tout petit peu exposés
alors donc ne joue pas sûr car il ya six
jours pas que ces trois mais elle joue
caf ou des deux mois la food & de voeux
voilà on avait dix à libérer aussi le
fou le souvient des deux bons on voit
bien que ce fou soit venir en c3 soit
simplement se développe ici parce qu'il
ya pas beaucoup d'autres cases un de ces
cases là aussi c'est attaquable sylvie
viant g5 se fout il va se faire attaquer
s'il ya ou 3 il peut se faire attaquer à
tout moment par cas et des cinq
cavaliers pts 5 rebonds alors en d2 il
est tranquille il attendra plus tard de
savoir où se placer et avoue se placer
mieux aider les patients des deux
missions mieux se placer petit rock et
la voilà d'ailleurs voilà donc elle
préfère ne pas sortir son cavalier
derrière sa dame qui pose poserait des
problèmes à la dame exposés comme ça
peut pas rentrer à la maison d'un coup
rend d'abord la maison tout en créant
une petite batterie la dame fou pour
venir peut-être échanger se fout g7 qui
est quand même un fou puissant puisque
le centre est ouvert au sens où les îles
est pas bloqué pour l'instant à tout
moment les noirs pouvaient ou pourront
menacer eu quatre fous prendre b2 des
choses comme ça bon maintenant que la
dame et océans pour contrôler b2 aussi
voilà c'est un coup très solide de
développement on prépare la sortie du
cavalier tout en consolidant les cases
noires henri calef scène c'est pas très
ambitieux ceni mais apparemment de deux
recueils f5
à bombay c'est vrai que là bon on
cherche à mieux placé son cavalier à
laurent fcag bien sûr il vise à la casse
des quatre bien sûr casse des quatre
avec la dame qui est là on essaie de
contenir les deux pions blancs au centre
ici on attend de sortir le fou ici c'est
8 parce qu'il faut lui trouver une bonne
case qui est pas évident peut-être on
veut le mettre à 1,6 mais est ce qu'il
est vraiment efficace on assiste
peut-être sans doute oui mais aussi
sipos fait attaquer par kg 5 faudrait
préparer en jouant d'abord h6 mais on
peut pas jouer à 6 à cause d'eux
justement fait tant que localité en 7 il
y avait la batterie ici qui taper dessus
khalef 5 pas un petit oeil sur a6 ou
simon c'est un beau coup 1.5 carrier à
trois on sort là aussi les pièces en a
trois pourquoi on a trois parce qu'il
veut sans doute revenir en c4 effet
exercé une petite pression sur cinq
à noter que les deux caves à liffré
pression et le fou pourrait venir en c3
exerçant une pression triple sur cinq
pourrait de façon être a obligé les
noirs de défendre par m6 qui serait un
tout petit peu qui pourrait être un tout
petit peu en jouant m6 ici un tout petit
peu affaiblissant voilà pourquoi
faiblissant et bien parce que ça
bloqueurs et l'action du fou g7
si on jouait 6 me le faisait 7
quand même but sur son pion voilà et en
plus ça affaiblit la cette grande
diagonale avait des effets possibles
il faut provoquer les affaiblissements
aussi il faut pas attendre qu'ils
viennent tout seuls
voilà la cavaille des quatre tranquille
donc à de solides
voilà on est bien protégé en et katia
pas de problème on peut échanger une
pièce d'un cahier centralisée c'est bien
on a libéré aussi des cases pour le fou
maintenant il peut venir avec cinq ans
j'ai quatre éventuellement c'est un bon
coup il y en a 10 ans taux un oui à
voter aussi bien sûr ce cavalier attaqué
aux 2 fallait faire quelque chose le
coup le plus naturel ces deux autos 1
c'est pas un mauvais coup la tour est
bien placée en eux un puisque tôt ou
tard les blancs vont sans doute je veux
trois des quatre des choses comme ça
essayez d'ouvrir le jeu ou aux 4 et d4
et la tour sera là pour soutenir le pion
central plus tard donc c'est même si
elle paraît pas forcément très bien
placée elle l'est en fait puisque ce
plan est susceptible d'être mobile dans
l'avenir à l'avenir en tout cas en effet
elle était que défensive parce qu'on
voit mal les blancs tout cas dans ce
type de position ou le centre est pas
bloqué voilà sous g4 voilà lecavalier
ont bougé le fou susceptible de bouger
alors là les noirs n'ont pas peur d'un
coup comme h3 puissent qu'ils
échangeraient un vraiment en f3
peut-être même du cavalier d'abord car
il prend en échec sa force la reprise du
pion d'ailleurs puisque sur fonds prend
il y aurait peut-être france 3 et
et s'affaiblir et terriblement par
contre là le rock
enfin la structure blanche en tout cas
l'europe non puisqu'il aurait beaucoup
de plans devant le roi mais le pion des
trois serait tout seul les pions serait
séparé des pions doublé ça serait une
catastrophe un nom il faut pas permettre
ça donc les blancs voient la prennent en
d4
c'est plus simple il faut éviter ce
désastre et l'appui on prend alors puis
on prend pourquoi pas donc le pion vient
en d4
c'est un bon coup le fou g7 gagne un peu
plus de puissance puisque belle option
étant plus loin de lui mais ils
contrôlent plus de cases
voilà tout simplement c'est aussi simple
que ça et ce pion en quelque sorte aussi
bine maintien en place les deux pions d2
d3 et o2 dire que les noirs on exerce
une petite pression notamment sur trois
est donc ce pion efforts il est il est
puissant les blancs peuvent pas
l'attaquer vraiment donc il est bien
défendue puis de toute façon on pourra y
est on pour jouer plus tard tour ses
huit baies si c'est celle qu'on peut
consolider ce pion aussi si on veut même
si c'est pas forcément une bonne idée en
affaiblir ici un il est bien protégé ça
suffit on peut recycler de cavaliers à 6
plus tôt on peut venir en ces sept ans
le 6 qui sur contrôle des cas c'est
possible aussi
on peut aussi envisager maintenant de
faire pression sur la colonne eux on a
un pion arriérés mais ne rien en e2 il
est encore sur sa case initiale mais il
est arriérée un petit peu aérée bon il
peut te soutenu par le curé f2 tous
joués 3 mais ça à faiblir à son collègue
voilà donc quand même là
on a l'impression ici tout de suite que
bell et noir ont réussi leurs débuts
dans une position agréable pas de pas de
faiblesses leurs structures de pions et
scène etc les blancs qui sont bons on
voit bien qu'ils sont un petit peu en
retrait ils sont sur trois rangées alors
que les noirs ont un deux trois quatre
cinq rangées quasiment avec deux pièces
sur la sur la cinquième c'est les noirs
sont actifs voilà donc le nom ont bien
réussi leur débuts pas de problème ils
ont au moins égaliser si ce n'est plus
faux âge 6 pourquoi pas les blancs
veulent échanger g7 pourquoi ben oui ce
fou quand même qu'on l'a dit il est un
peu plus puissants qui contrôlent des 4
contre pas mal de cases intéressante se
fout des 2000 n'était pas hyper actif en
échange une des pièces un peu passive
face à une pièce active coup logique
tours 8
alors attention tour 8 non seulement
j'attaque le 2 mai je menace si
éventuellement de jouer tout de suite et
d'éviter leur échange
voilà donc là on n'y changent d'abord
voilà comme ça c'est réglé
et maintenant faut s'occuper de ce
problème là on à tour est fou qui tape
sur deux et voilà dam des deux alors
regardez ça secoue a l'air de rien mais
il faut le noter
la dame reste sur casse noix donc ça
pour savoir sur quelle couleur mettre la
dame parce qu'on aurait pu se dire en
lamé dans ces deux bons ces deux déjà on
arrive une case au cavalier bon les
mythes on peut dire c'est pas grave
puisque je le veux le maître de toute
façon en c4 bon admettons mais de toute
façon
c'est pas la question s'il revend ces
deux les moins actifs parce que d'abord
la moins de diagonale - moins longue ici
c'est un peu plus long sur place noir et
c'est plus long de ce côté là le nombre
de cases contre les parades à mes plus
grands ici et en plus la dame et de la
couleur opposée au full circle adam
l'eau en fête joue un petit peu le rôle
du fou de cases noires cas disparu
à noter pour les noirs c'est pareil le
fouet de surface blanche et la dame et
surclasse noir donc c'est souvent le cas
à l'évidence il faut jamais généraliser
dans tous les cas mais c'est souvent le
cas il est bon de mettre la dame sur le
coup leur opposer du fou dame 17
alors voilà donc la typique elle le met
sur la même couleur que fou pour me
contredire mais non mais elle veut faire
sans doute la même chose peut-être joué
pour moi je crois en tout cas
l'empêchent cherche 3 je crois que
j'aurais peut-être poser des problèmes
ou ovales fou sylvain f5 on pouvait
jouer g4 est là si le foot oublié de
revenir en russie ce il bouche l'action
de sa tour c'est pas terrible qu'est
l'humain dame 17 je lis les tours aussi
et je peux donc j'en paie cherche trois
aussi jolie les tours je veux pouvoir
doubler un tour sept tours 8
et faire pression max sur une pression
maximum sur deux câbles et ses 4 c'est
là on avait dix cavaliers il avait envie
de venir on s'éclate depuis le début ça
y est il vient alors attention parce que
les pièces blanches se rapproche du
centre se fout contrôle des cases
centrale ce cavalier aussi contre les
quatre centrales est atteint sur le nom
les noirs ou un cavalier l'acquis qui
pour l'instant est un tout petit peu en
jeu se signant un coût 1 ils peuvent
venir vers le centre un cas nécessaire
tout cas les c5 et il sera proche de 6
il se rapproche du centre bon mais c'est
pas évident de trouver une bonne bonne
case à ce qu'on valait peut-être c'est
cette petite ronde des cinq peut-être
ces sept dessins bima il faut soutenir
par une pièce où on est loin pour
pour échanger avec une pièce ou innocent
tant qu'à des changes alors f6 alors f6
alors l'idée des noirs ici c'est de
contrôler très certainement la classe de
seine voilà on veut contrôler le 5 pour
empêcher le cavalier a jamais d'y aller
parce que évidemment ce cavalier
ils rêvent d'aller en 5 1 fourchette dam
tour 1 to catch attack les deux pièces
est bon il faudrait le protéger par f4
s'est pas fait mais bon en tout cas on
l'empêchent ça c'est un premier point
c'est pas le seul on se libère aussi des
quatre planches ici peut-être pour le
fou sur le fond pourra revenir en russie
et en f 7
il remplacera le pion qui parti il
restera actif en contrôle en cas
centrale en d5 et permettra au tour de
ceux liés au centre pour attaquer ou
deux voilà c'est un bon coup et 6e ça
affaiblit pas vraiment le roi parce que
les blancs n'ont pas de a suffisamment
de pièces pour lancer une attaque contre
le roi et puis surtout la position ne
s'y prête pas n'y a pas de colonne
ouverte n'y a pas de diagonale h4 alors
ça c'est un coup prophylactique
positionnelle on prendre l'air quoi on
prend un peu d espace
par contre on ont dit adieu à tout
jamais à jouer à trois on pourra plus
jamais sûr même si plus tard les noirs
maintenant joues la dame on peut plus
jouer h 3o hashcash 4 à noter ici aussi
l'autre facteur c'est que la dame et se
classent noir maintenant les pions ici
ici pions contrôle des cases noires
voilà la dame aussi voilà donc c'est un
jeu là ici pions et dames remplace le
fouquet partie tandis que c'est le fou
de cases blanches qui lui contrôle donc
les cases blanches
voyez comme ça se complètent bien là ça
fait voilà on a et le cavalier
d'ailleurs aussi la ici contrôler les
cases noires oui tout les cas ce
contrôle est ici ça fait beaucoup de
cases mais bon on sait pas voyez bien
que ces cases même s'ils sont contrôlés
donc c'est pas non plus
rien de dangereux dans le camp moi aller
chercher avec sa tour 7 propre
tranquille on voit bien que on prépare
le doublement des tours sur la colonne
est donc le pilonnage un des pions et 2
qui est déjà attaqué par le fonds c'est
simple envoyez les échelles jouer comme
ça ccm pid de 4 à alors ça c'est une
décision sans doute au bon moment juste
avant que les tours soient liés c'est
certainement le bon moment pour le faire
donc que 4 si les noirs ne prennent pas
en passant eh bien c'est fini il y aura
plus jamais de pression sur le colonel
puisque ce pion au cas très très très
très bien défendue par le pion détroit
ce pion détroit lui-même étant couvert
par le pion des quatre noirs peuvent pas
l'attaquer donc la structure blanche
serait très solide et il aurait un peu
les mains libres maintenant pour lancer
pourquoi pas ce qu'on appelle une
attaque de minorité c'est à dire balance
et b4 à quatre baies 5 voilà essayer de
casser d'aller attaquer ce trio de pions
avec ce duo deux pions contre 3,12
l'attaquent de minorité voilà j'ai moins
de pions mais je vais donc comment je
vais justement lancé une attaque avec
les tours derrière et essayer de casser
ça pendant qu'on a solidifié le centre
donc les noirs ont pas intérêt à laisser
le centre blanc se solidifier sinon les
blancs prendrait sans doute une petite
initiative avec cette possibilité d'
attaque donc on prend 2,3 voilà c'est un
coup logique en plus puisque ça
affaiblit la structure de pions blancs
là les blancs toute prise en 3 est pas
bonne en fait donc c'est pour ça que le
4 était quand même très responsable si
je prend du plomb f2 c'est pas bon du
tout hein c'est pas bon du tout parce
qu'alors là par contre ça affaiblit
vraiment le roi avec un pion j'ai trois
là qui est pas même pas protégé donc on
pourrait simplement essayé de l'attaquer
à une fois et puis ça pose des problèmes
tout de suite
détroit aussi est faible maintenant
puisqu'on va pouvoir doubler là aussi
sur la colonne des pouvoirs même triplé
et comment défendre des 3 ça va être
chaud donc difficile de prendre le pion
f
presque deux pions cible au centre plus
un pion nouvelle faible ça fait beaucoup
donc elle prend du cavalier donc ça
c'est son idée après avoir joué quatre
et là on se dit bell et noir ont quand
même davantage parce que
soit ça c'est quand même un pion
extrêmement faible en plus je peux
l'attaqué par câble et ses scènes tout
de suite qu'il est possible et qui tout
de suite mais la pression mais la
pression sur détroit est ce que c'est
possible qu'elle ait des 1000 très
certainement son aurait été possible de
jouer ça d'attaquer tout de suite non
non attendez on fouille info ont pris
ici d'abord la cavale de trois ici le
fou g4 et emprise on va pas donner le
fou contre le cavalier se seraient pas
bien ce serait pas une bonne idée dans
une finale où il a des plans des deux
côtés il vaut mieux garder c'est fou
voilà donc papa ce coup qui vendent pas
bon c'est une très mauvaise suggestions
issifou 1,6
voilà faut 6 simplement voilà je recule
en six dont on comprend mieux l'idée des
pcistes maintenant je peux envisager de
venir en aide cette et je vais pouvoir
masse et des pièces lourdes au centre
pour attaquer ce pion là un petit peu
arriérée là un peu tout seul puis isolé
alors les blancs il avance tout de suite
toujours ce thème
je mets sur cases noires je contrôle des
petites cases noires avec le fou et je
peux peut-être l'idée de 2
lifan ou ici dans cette position c'est
très certainement de jouer des cinq des
cinq force forcerez une prise prise
prise prise enfin un ensemble de prises
qui à la fin et bien laisse une position
aplanissent tard trois pions contre 8 3
puis 6 2 contre 2 contre 2 puisqu'on
aurait éliminé on élimine un tueur isolé
contre un pion qui est lié à aux trois
autres ici donc c'est pas un intérêt des
noirs de laisser pousser des simples
alors les noirs jouent tour à 8 qu'ils
ont peur ils empêchent des cinq puisque
si je joue des simples non regardez ça
marche pas cosy attention parce que là
cette puissance ici va se réveiller
contre la la tour e 1 donc simplement
prendre du fou mais voyons on peut pas
reprendre du cavalier on peut si vous
prenez le cavalier vous allez vous
prendre tout reprend pour prend tout
reprend dans prend et après je peux
reprendre tranquillement et la dame
n'attaque plus des 5 donc je peux pas je
peux pas reprendre des 5
voilà donc la sas a perdu on est donc
c'est pas une bonne idée donc tour à 8
d438 et là un coup
on so lide mais pas extraordinaire non
plus des trois bons alors b3 l'idée
c'est bon d'abord c'est solide mais ya
pas trop de choix en fait c'est que ce
fou là aussi si l'attaqué quand même à
deux sarres si je veux pour ramener
cette tour en défense et je suis un peu
obligé de faire attention parce que là
le plan d'eau où on peut le prendre et
les blancs peuvent pas enfermer de fou
on peut il n'y a pas de coupes renfermé
fou et c'est un pion de l'ale à la fin
en finale qui va peser lourd parce que
là on a trois pions l'acquis qui vont
devenir extrêmement dangereux et quand
ils vont se mettre en mouvement on va
avoir des concessions va pas donner un
pion gratuit comme ça y'a pas de raison
ici de le faire et pas d'attaquants vu
contre leurs ouailles à rien du tout
donc il est hors de question donc on
joue b3 dans cette idée là on joue b3
plutôt que à 3 à noter que à 3 serait
possible aussi mais à trois on pourra
permettre aux noirs de jouer four b3 et
foulée 3 qui contrôle la casse d un nom
qui va poser des problèmes sur des coups
comme autour des 1 on va jouer fumay et
revin et la tourette attaque être obligé
de bouger et on aura joué un coup pour
rien donc qu'en jouant b3 on en bon on
enlève des cases ou fou voilà c'est ça
l'idée qu'elle et ses 7 à saillé alors
là des noirs verrouille la casse des
cinq donc là les blancs peuvent pas
jouer dessin si les noirs arrivent à
verrouiller cette case et bien ce pion
risque de subir un siège et de tomber
alors s'il tombait et non des chances de
gain quoi du coup ça changerait tout
mais vous allez voir que les blancs ont
des ressources simplement alors dame b 4
4 attention la tacc bessède tout
simplement tout en gardant un oeil sur
le pion des quatre marques lenor peuvent
pas laisser prendre le pion bessette le
problème c'est que si ce pion bouge
c'est cette fois le pion c6 qui
deviendra faible et oui attaqué par le
fou ici et on pourrait jouer simplement
dame à 4 par exemple attaquera la fois
ces six et à 7 ou alors on pourrait
aussi jouer tour à ses seins à taxer 6
tout simplement et noir ont des soucis
et c'est ce pion devient ou presque
aussi faible que le pion des 4
presqu'un jeudi parce que quand il est
pas loin de ses copains alors que lui
est vraiment isolé donc assez délicat
donc là les coûts doivent être très
précis du côté blanc la position est
sans doute encore à égal mais à
condition de jouer extrêmement précis
parce que si les noirs ont le temps de
consolider et d'empêcher ce pion à
jamais de bouger ils risquent pouvoir
s'organiser et renverser la vapeur et
prendre en fait refaire le faire un
siège pénible à supporter mon cas les
dessins est logique
voilà qu'à il essaime ses joues bloc ça
y est j'ai un bloqueur donc ça c'est un
superbe le clan gênant on dit un
cavalier donc on va les changer comme ça
pas de problème mme premiers échanges
vous prend la regarde et techniques tout
reprend et la dame prend
voilà ça c'est l'étonnant parce qu'ici
alors enfin c'est étonnant moitié disent
encore les noirs auraient pu tenter tout
reprend avec l'idée ben si fou prend je
reprends de la dame parce que si je
reprends de la dame
eh bien je laisse le plus isolé parce
que si je reprends du pion mais ses
pions isolé contrepoint isolé
c'est égal quoi mais je peux pas parce
que la dame ici en plus en venant des
quatre gardes et en plus elle avait un
petit oeil sur la tour donc un cas de
prises en d5 ici et on peut pas faire
dame tran mais sûr parce qu'on perd la
tour voilà donc d'où la puissance de
secours
je reviens en arrière pour vous montrer
quand même voilà ce coup très fort ici
d'un bep cattrall a tout calculé dit fan
ou dans cette partie ici d'un mecha à la
fois un petit oeil sur 7 à la vue c'est
les échanges possibles et à la fin la
tour qui est en prise ici et la taxe sur
bessette en même temps donc arriver
cette calais prend fou prend tout
reprend donc mariam ouzou copte pour
dans prend en île en mai si tu ne
changes pas les dames bien tu vas bouger
la dame et après moi je prends en g2 et
tu restes avec un gros pions isolé et gc
- qu'est la colonne en plus c'est moi
qui ai la colonne ouverte
on peut dire que l'énorme avantage alors
je sais pas si c'est gagnant mais en
tout cas ça doit être pénible à jouer
d'en prendre cette tour prend dans la
classe était forcé donc on vient de le
voir
et maintenant simplement fou prend ses
prend là on voit bien tout de suite que
la position est symétrique de pions de
pions trois pions de ce côté contre
trois pions et enfin les deux pions lieu
en plus une finale deux tours et on sait
que c'est extrêmement difficile à gagner
il faut des circonstances spéciales et
là hop à la tour c 1
on craint pas bien sûr tour ces deux
tours 2 pardon qui met sur la seconde
parce que nous aussi on va sur la 7ème
échec en plus et on ramasse donc si on
ne crée rien et maria me dit tu me
prends aucun risque
elle ramène le roi vers le centre
tranquillement les blancs aussi aux f1
mais sûr on pourra pas aller à eux deux
le 1 ou 2 puisque enfin en tout cas pas
tout de suite puisque la tour empêche
ici mais les noirs en jouant aussi se
permettent heureux de on pourrait jouer
revenant sait ce qu'elle fait voilà
trois des six roi des trois est
maintenant pour ces sept on conteste la
colonne tranquillement toro ou tooro
cette tour c'est un tour c7 est partie
nulle part répétition la partie est
vraiment nul nul nul ici de chez nul
c'est quand même très bien joué alors on
peut dire que ici dans cette partie j'ai
l'impression la psychologie comment que
maria musique tout cas marqué un très
bon demi point parce que parce que la
manière était là je pense qu'elle a même
pris l'avantagé aurait peut-être pu
jouer des coups plus précis dans cette
partie pour essayer d'augmenter cette ce
petit avantage
on n'a pas réussi à les annuler en tout
cas sans grande difficulté c'est que la
partie précédente
alors on peut tempérer ce jugement dix
ans mais oui mais dit fan elle elle mène
le championnat puisqu'elle mène d'un
point c'est pas elle de prendre des
risques donc à la limite
on pourrait considérer aussi que l'ifa
n'attend que son adversaire prenne
elle-même des risques et puis et puis
finalement la cale en poche le point en
réfutant on réfute en une attaque trop
trop ambitieuse c'est le problème c'est
qu'à un moment donné bon il n'ya que dix
parties et voilà maintenant il reste
plus que 5 est bon alors ceci dit je
pense que le moment crucial du match on
en arrive puisque maria zitiou qu'on
aura donc les blancs à la prochaine donc
sans doute deux fois les blancs et puis
donc à partir de là elle peut espérer
maintenant renverser la vapeur pour faut
voir faut voir ce qui va se passer dans
la suite 2 du championnat
merci donc de m'avoir suivi pour cette
donc cinquième partie du championnat du
monde féminin 2016
et puis donc rendez vous pour la 6e ou
bien on espère qu'elle va envoyer du
bois la maria music uk on aura qu on
aura droit à une belle partie alors
c'est pas le moment non plus de prendre
des risques excessifs mais mais mais ça
approche il faut pas le faire la
dernière partie faut le faire avant il
faut se décider
voilà merci à bientôt donc sur des
modèles tv pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde féminin 2016
au revoir